nicki minaj without a shadow of a doubt
and without any fear of contradiction
was the rudest little madam i've ever
had the displeasure to meet america's
got talent around 2006
seven she turned up as our guest on our
show and my sons were all quite young
all under 12 i think all wanted to meet
nicki minaj no refuse to do it rude
little madden never coming on my show
again
i think joe rogan is one of the most
interesting characters in the world
right now he has a huge following i
don't agree with some of the stuff that
he said particularly about vaccines and
so on but i do think that he's one of
those guys he'll get experts in he
doesn't agree with and he'll spend three
hours debating the issue and he'll
sometimes say you know what you've
changed my mind you're right well that's
what a democracy should be about the
whole fuss was spotify and neil young
quitting over joe rogan just showed a
kind of old dinosaur really he doesn't
get what joe rogan is joe rogan really
is a controversialist who likes to have
arguments and he doesn't mind losing
some of them but what you do every time
you listen to joe rogan's interviews you
learn something because he always gets
really interesting people are we need
more people like joe rogan
who i may not agree with about
everything who i find interesting
compelling and who teach me stuff
then we do probably neil young's with
great respect to mr yup
i didn't really understand nfts until i
sat next to this very charming guy at
the gq awards who told me eventually his
name was beeple and that he used to sell
his pictures uh digital art for about a
hundred dollars a pop and then one day
several years ago some bloke in san
francisco paid him 69 million dollars
and at that point i thought i need to
know more about nfts and i particularly
know need to work out how to make one
that makes me 69 million dollars so it's
a fascinating new form of art i don't
feel snobbish about it i think all art
is whatever it's worth to somebody who
wants to pay that kind of money and have
it but i don't really understand it's a
bit like cryptocurrency probably a
little bit old to completely understand
what this is all about but my kids all
think this is fantastic
well electric cars are obviously the
future you can see with elon musk and
the success he's been having that
ultimately we'll all end up in an
electric car and then probably there'll
be something after that as well the idea
we're still pumping diesel and oil into
cars and polluting the world into an
early death seems to me completely
ridiculous so i think the sooner we get
electric cars to be cheap and affordable
and there's enough power places to power
up your car around the countries then
that's going to be good for the planet
and good for all of us we should all
want to have a cleaner environment to
live in and there's no doubt that
polluting cars right now are a major
contributor to the issues we have with
climate change
i love cricket i probably love cricket
more than anything else in the entire
world and i i really love fish and chips
so that shows you how much i love
england but we've gone through a rough
patch at the moment and what really
worries me is we're putting
a massive premium on t20 and the smaller
forms of the game over test cricket and
test cricket is the golden goose and if
we're not very very careful he's going
to die and we have got to protect test
print to look after county cricket and
go back to encouraging people to play
the longer form of the game because the
whole point of qriket is it's so long
and often so boring that americans never
want to play it so they're never going
to beat us it's just one of the few
sports in the world where we can always
beat the americans that's why we should
keep chess cricket
you